اعاده كسوف اليوم الخميس فتح المعبر
الحدوديه الرئيسيه مع صربيا بعد ازالته
حاجز ادى الى اغلاقه وكان الرئيس الصربي
واليكساندر فوسيتش قد ذكر في وقت متاخر
امس الاربعاء ان الصربه سيبداون ازاله
حواجزهم في جميع انحاء الشمالي كسوف اليوم
الخميس في خطوه قد تنزع فتيل التوترات
المستمره منذ اسابيع والتي اثارت مخاوف من
اندلاع اشتباكات جديده في البلقان جاء ذلك
عقب اطلاق سراح ضابط شرطه سابق من صربي
كوسوفو تسبب اعتقاله في ازمه كبيره بين
صربيا وكسفه واثار مخاوف طولك ولم يتضح
حال الفود متى يمكن ان يبدا الصرف في
تفكيك الحواجز المكونه من شاحنات ثقيله
ومركبات اخرى وخيام
طلبت منهم ان يقدر ما اتيت من اجله وطلبت
منه البدء في ازاله الحواجز واعطاء فرصه
للتحدث والسلام والثقه هذا ليس بالامر
السهل ولا يمكن الانتهاء منه في حضور
ساعتين كما يعتقد البعض ولكن اما في غضون
24 او 48 ساعه
الجزيره الرسول
هل بدا الصرف في تنفيذي وعودهم بتفكيك
الحواجز
واو
اعزوفو
تقريبا
حواجز ولكن بعضها ما يزال موجوده وبعده
الطرق ما تزال مغلقه لذلك
الطرق تتحكم فيها الصربيون
اوف ليله الماضيه الرئيس صربيا قال ان
قاده ال الجاليه الصربيه في كوسوفو
وافقت على بدء
الحواجز لكن في وقت متاخر البعض قال ان
كان هناك بعض الاستفزاز وانه ليس من السهل
للاستمرار
الصرب بداوا تحقيقا وعلى ضوء النتائج
الاولى
بحايد البث
ولكن تم بدا العمل على ازالتها وهناك
تفاؤل حذر من قبل السلطات في كوسوفو
وهناك ايضا احترام حقوق السياده لهذه لهذا
البلد اذا طلب طلب
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
للقيام بضغط كبير على الحكومه الصربيه
وهناك همم لاعب اخر هو روسيا هناك مخاوف
من
وجود رغبه في فتح جبهه جديده في اوروبا
وهذا هو هذه هي المخاوف من عدد من البلدان
ومن الولايات المتحده لذلك فالجميع الان
يشعرون بالقلق
وهناك ساعه الى عدم زياده
التصعيد شكرا لك من متروفيتشا شماليكو
سوفيماراسل جزيره الرسول سيردار